I don't need to tell you this week was a
horrific week but at a time when we
should be coming together the MSM can't
resist attacking our president president
Trump also venting his frustration at US
courts we also have to come up with
punishment that's far quicker and far
greater what we have right now is a joke
and it's a laughingstock press secretary
Sarah Sanders mischaracterizing the
president's remarks he said that the
system of justice in this he said the
process has people calling us a joke and
calling us a laughingstock I see that
see it right there
CNN wants you to think that Trump called
our justice system a joke and then
Huckabee Sanders flat-out lied about it
and it looks like that's what happened
or did it did you really lie maybe
you're not remembering it right you know
what it feels a little dark in here let
me get out my trusty gas lights yes much
better
where was I oh yeah you think Sanders
was lying about Trump
maybe you're just remembering Trump's
words wrong how good is your memory
really what did you have for breakfast
three months ago you can't remember I
didn't think so
and who are you to question Trump's
words he's the president know who else
was President Abraham Lincoln they
called him on his tape so Trump must be
honest too maybe you're wondering why
this gas lake keeps getting bigger maybe
you think I'm trying to Gaslight you
right now
and that is disorienting you with
aggressive misinformation and pointless
non sequiturs dobby ridiculous hem on TV
you can trust me
we think the same way in fact my
thoughts are your thoughts and your mind
is mere clay waiting to be shaped by my
righteous supple American hands dick was
all a misunderstanding
obviously president truck didn't have
time to call America's court system a
joke after Tuesday's attack he was too
busy taking action President Trump
reacting with outrage to the attacks
focusing on punishment talking about the
death penalty which is unusual for a
president also blasting the legal system
his response couldn't be more different
than what he said after the mass
shooting in Las Vegas and the days
following Vegas president Trump
essentially said it wasn't the time to
talk about gun laws okay when it comes
to the gun debate I like most rational
Americans I'm in favor of a mandatory
waiting period to talk about guns after
a shooting but the war on terror on the
other hand needs immediate action and
the path forward isn't always clear what
drives people to commit monstrous acts
of terror like the one this week in
Manhattan our greatest minds have spent
years searching for the answer to this
question our greatest mind found the
problem in less than a day a program
that gives immigration opportunities to
people from underrepresented countries I
am today starting the process of
terminating the diversity lottery
program diverse eree and diversity
lottery okay yeah now now diversity is
an American value diversity is great
what's this word diverse serene
how did it get here
does it sound like an American word must
have infiltrated Trump's body
radicalized itself somewhere in the
throat region and attacked his mouth
which is why we must get rid of
diversity and it's lottery - we need
extreme linguistic vetting a diversity
didn't act alone it had inside help from
sneaky grandpa Chuck Schumer the
president blaming New York's Democratic
Senator Chuck Schumer for implementing
the program and endangering the country
Schumer helped craft the bill that was
signed into law by President George HW
Bush in 1990 but in 2013 Schumer was
also part of a bipartisan group known as
the gang of eight that pushed to in the
diversity program huh the gang of eight
you heard it there Chuck Schumer was a
gang member his gang sign is slowly
pushing his glasses up the bridge of his
nose that's that's the last thing
somebody senators see Trump then called
out the most vicious weapon our nation
faces political correctness we have to
get much less politically correct was so
politically correct that we're afraid to
do anything he's right
political correctness is hobbling us do
you have any idea how much energy our
president wastes trying to not say
racial slurs if if he could instead
focus that energy for good he could have
defeated Isis before Obama even had the
chance to found it
but our our president has a way forward
is the deepest respect for our
institutions and faith and due process
which is why he tweeted death panel day
that belongs in the great book of
presidential quotes along with asked not
what the death penalty can do for you
asked what death penalty can death
penalty for death penalty death penalty
Donald Trump is quick to point the
finger at immigration political
correctness diver sri chuck schumer ii
and some might say that his reactions
feed a dangerous culture of fear that
he's stoking tensions that create an
environment that has been proven to only
lead to more acts of violence but i mean
how could you even think that the
president only has the best of
intentions unlike those Antipa wide
receivers out there you wouldn't do
anything to hurt you you're just
confused who could blame you
i mean it's all in your head
[Music]